the
mdm goals and irony two too and
well it's now here in the power supply for
the 2100
again this admittedly very
solid variant
yes black can play all sorts of stuff here
for example that would also
do
that I find it funny that way now it can
i take and play the four
looks because
it is not yet dramatic like
before black but he has to be very careful
that i don't change very
often
the bishops on the diagonal at some point and then it
can really be a problem for
him  that everything is on white here
so a4 b5 and so on
jumper the four for example or
similar moves
and this part is not exactly nice
was not
made six times everything was cheerful continue on
white
try let’s drive now get a
little exchanged here
so hedi damm would also like
to play b 1 or 2, ideally
i can also play dead two if he
now n  always then I
can easily get to b 2 on the next move
and now he will have to swap the bishops at some point
because otherwise the
pressure on the diagonal will become too
uncomfortable yes it will come to pass the question is
now well well I'll first
get out the
so and so  now you have this position here
how do you do that now best
likes the train actually
and he still has the idea maybe really
stupid you jump here for example
just swap everything away and
then said is okay or what
amazing yes but
well good the swap  is of course also
good for me but
actually the ladies are like
now here better than you tell
springer ag 44 said it doesn’t matter anyway
ok I thought the unpleasant
well ok I’ll do f4
now something like that according to the program me
everything further on white
such
a nice field
now i didn't really have it on the
screen a bit stupid
there we have on 1 simon so
unpleasant only a bit  a bit alright
if everyone does
n't want to know anything about it
yes i probably should have just
exchanged the lady
i really don't care about it because i should have had
the
ladies ready now
probably should do springer goes here
so now come now  namely the
queen I was still ok here
so I can hardly wait to
exchange here although this is now just a
totally
one-sided position he cannot play e5
I simply have a room advantage
so I can also make the 4g five
should you make
the 5
still can't make
ski fans
so let's go after the 4
yes I mean you also have to get on the
G8 I now
started playing
on such a one-way street
training
man oh man I'm
stupid he played that so badly
to scatter
like silly  how silly so i have to go to
a4
a shame who really has such a nice position
we need we can hope he
has later  so bad
ciao
now he's running on the
21st crap
what do I find something to
be in the game
yes probably not good yes so
directly helps to run forward here
yes actually a game for a goal I
can do everything possible springer
improve the 24 votes as you like
then at the end the cucumber always ended up on the 7 but
I did it here but of course totally
rubbish totally rubbish
yes of course I originally wanted to
take f pawns but then of course go
you didn't really see that
and it
really sets a bit  goofy
looks a bit uncomfortable
in kamminke